hallo liebe zuschauer und herzlich
willkommen zurück bei easy därmen wir
sind heute wieder in münster mit dem
money kari ja und wir wollen heute meine
villa die sich treffen wir immer meine
wieder zufällig war ihr german was
machst du hier
ich bin grad auf der durchreise du ich
würde sagen dann sparen wir nicht direkt
mit ein oder er weiß was wieder was ich
gesehen hab letztens da hat ein
zuschauer hat einen kommentar über dich
geschrieben
zudem sehen was in 14 kommentare der
junior fox nett geschrieben
peter seine haare sehen so komisch aus
abgehakt ich weiß dass ich da gedacht
hab da hab ich gedacht
eigentlich müssten wir mal eine folge
beim friseur drehen mit dir lass uns
jetzt gleich machen oder auch echt
hilfreich wenn ihr bock gehabt weil ich
bräuchte glaube ich echt mal neuen
haarschnitt martin auch warum nicht
münsters groß
ja
vor einem monat schrieb junior fox net
unter unser video easy german 95 tanks
münster peter was ist mit deinem haar
passiert
das gefällt mir überhaupt nicht wohl zu
diesem satz nehmen wir heute stellung
wir haben peter hier
carina heute nämlich stellung wir
möchten euch zeigen wir nehmen eure
kommentare ernst will lesen sie nicht
nur alle wir nehmen sie auch ernst
deshalb geben heute mal mit peter zum
friseur und werden euch dabei mal zu
gucken lassen wie man in deutschland zum
friseur geht und welches vokabular man
dabei benutzt
wir sehen uns gleich drinnen im eliane
und team friseursalon hallo wenn ihr
chef sprechen ja wir haben jetzt im
wandbereich des salons platz genommen
und peter sucht sich gerade eine frisur
aus was hältst du davon ja alles schön
frisuren
da weiß man gar nicht was man muss man
haben will
was hast du denn sonst versuchen ja
eigentlich gehe ich nun mal immer
zufrieden und sagt einfach schreiben sie
haben sich bereit erklärt peter mal die
haare zu schneiden
dann kommen mit es geht erstmal los mit
der beratung welche frisur bekommt peter
am 1 was machst du beruflich rationieren
student das heißt weniger kommune
fürchtet das ist ja die drei millimeter
frisur der villa genau weitergeht
spatzen für sollte okay
von mir aus machen eher unauffällig
nicht nicht so extravagant diese an
rasierte abschnitte mit der maschine
natürlich gehe davon aus dass okay dass
peter ja auf jeden fall freue mich ganz
große veränderung bist du nicht zu haben
na ja da bin ich sehr konservativ kabine
davon zugleich peter fitz ich hole ich
fühle mich richtig aufgehoben jahr in
guten händen auf jeden fall
unter die wirbellosen hast du die sonst
ja da ich habe drei millimeter nach wird
er so kurz habe ich deine haare noch nie
gesehen ich hältst du dir so gefalle ich
euch denn das sollen die zuschauer
entscheiden
junior fox leidtut gefällt dir das war
das dein wille also janosch unser
kameramann hat gerade signalisiert er
hätte gern auch diese frisur gleich noch
william beschreiben uns doch mal was du
gerade hier machst
ich habe es gerade den haarschnitt an
rasierten anders sagt er in deutschland
an rasieren mit der drei millimetern
leichtes übergang habe ich schon
präsentiert peter was machst du denn
sonst so um deine zu pflegende sache war
ja eigentlich gar nicht so ich habe da
überhaupt keinen durchblick vorher
gehabt was machst du jetzt gerade
ich moderiere die haare gerade rp
bahnbenutzer sonst auch hd ja aber dann
schon dr
auf jeden fall besondere anlässe oder
auch mal so ein alltag lege auch mal im
alltag
eliane wir haben ja gerade erfahren du
kommst aus syrien wir haben ja ganz
viele zuschauer im arabischen raum die
deutsch lernen
vielleicht kannst du dir mal grüßen ich
spreche jetzt immer du sprichst
arabischer ich kann daran spricht ja
klar sicher ich habe auch in syrien
studiert zusätzlich maximal unsere
arabischsprachigen zuschauer grüßen
maraghy von einer realen bolus missouri
in die showrooms alarm zu retten war
jetzt in besonderem maß an meiner
landsleute julien ich habe mich nur
vorschlag vorgestellt wer bin ich dass
ich auch
julian kommen ich wünsche mir dass der
krieg unserem auftrag dass die menschen
sich wieder zurück nach hause
wenn die auch noch trauen lässt nichts
zu wünschen uns natürlich auch also
karriere ich weg schon der eliane macht
dass sie mit sehr viel herzblut und das
merkt man auf jeden fall gefällt dir das
gitter hier bin ich mensch hier kann ich
selber sein
hoffen wir dass nicht einfach treiben
sondern habe rein geht mir sehr geschämt
dass wir unsere friseur episode aus den
friseur-salon leon herner innenstadt in
münster ihr könnt auch gerne mal hier
vorbei kommen werdet auf deutsch auf
arabisch in jeder sprache französisch
italienisch alles angesprochen wenn
immer eine coole frisur haben wollt
kommt ihr zu ehren hier in der
innenstadt in der salzstraße in münster
danke liebe zuschauer nass petermann
florida wie findest du das ja mir
gefällt supergut ich frage mich nur wie
es dem junior fox mit jud gefällt als
die gefallen schreibt uns antwort uns
das ist jetzt die frage
junior fox net für dich wegen deines
kommentares haben wir bereits im friseur
geschickt wir hoffen das hat dir
gefallen
jeder hat eine schöne frisur bekommen
und wir wollen gerne von einfach ich
wissen was haltet ihr von wird das neue
frisur gibt sonst noch was was ihr zu
peter zu sagen habt sondern vielleicht
demnächst mal bungee jump bungee jumpen
oder so dann schreibt uns einfach und
vielleicht haben wir eine neue spannende
anregungen für die nächste sendung
danke fürs zuschauen wir hoffen euch hat
unser friseur vokabular heute gefallen
wir sehen uns nächste woche wieder bei
easy german und jetzt gehen peter und
ich kaufe den ice wieder
meine haare